we now take it for granted when we see
lines walking through water but really
it is completely unique and these lines
started to utilize the water to ambush
the Buffalo
there's a nice ramp up here going from
normal speed into fall speed to try and
get that that sense of speed across we
had this long scene in the film at some
point all about how muddy tar was having
a tough time of it and she and she was
struggling for hours for days for months
to try and feed herself off the curves
of the hood and so this is sort of an
extended montage of this hunting but
it's a beautiful moment and that you you
really do get to enjoy the rippling
muscles and to seen a lion running and
failing a lot of the time but really her
join journey was that she focused on
these young animals and brought them
down and slowly built up her strategies
and their tactics to try and eventually
kill Buffalo big Buffalo and each moment
like this is so unique and so beautiful
but we got to the point where we felt
like we were repeating ourselves with
the one sort of must catch after the
other and so we eventually chose the
ones that suited the film the best and
then had to take the others out and to
see as you say to see these animals
hunting in water was really what the
scene was about as well getting the
audiences used to the water as well as
on the same sort of curve that the land
was getting used to her water but
ultimately I think that it just became a
bloodfest
this was quite interesting where you see
that this little coffe with its intense
will to survive and courage actually
stops and confronts the slyness hoping
that's just by confronting it's going to
move the line s away scare the line is
off but of course it isn't inevitable at
that early age again real blood blowing
out to one side of the frame there and
it's so interesting because I think that
in the in the pre screenings that we had
of this people were anticipating fake
blood and so the real blood is even more
horrifying